hello everyone my name is Morgan Shirley
and in this talk I'd like to tell you
about some recent research I've done
about equality Oracles in communication
complexity
this work is joint with Tony and potassi
at Columbia
and ADI shridman at the academic College
of Tel avivo
let me start by defining the standard
communication model we have two parties
Alice and Bob Alice gets some input X
and Bob gets some input y
the party's exchange messages according
to a protocol with the goal of computing
some joint function of their output
we say such a protocol is efficient if
the number of bits exchanged is poly
logarithmic in the lengths of their
inputs note that linear communication is
trivial
for this talk I'll be focusing on
functions whose outputs are binary
what I've described here is the basic
deterministic model of communication
in this work we're interested in what
happens when you add extra capabilities
to this model here are three extended
models of particular interest
the first is the randomized model where
Alice and Bob have access to a source of
Randomness and are allowed some small
chance of computing the function
incorrectly
the second is the non-deterministic
model
here approver sends some short witness
string to Allison Bob that can depend on
their inputs
Alice and Bob can then communicate to
verify this Witness
the third variation on the standard
model we'll be considering is the Oracle
model
fix some function G in addition to
sending messages to each other Alice and
Bob can now also send messages to some
Oracle who will evaluate the function G
on these messages they are only charged
one bit of communication to query the
Oracle like this
similarly to oracle's In classical
Computing Theory this Oracle model
allows us to model reductions in
communication complexity
in this talk we'll investigate what
happens when we combine multiple of
these extended models
two-party communication functions can be
represented by matrices
each row of the Matrix will correspond
to a possible value of x each column
will correspond to a possible value of y
in the entry where they intersect will
be the output of the function on that
pair of inputs
the example shown here is the
communication Matrix for the equality
function the equality function which is
the main character of today's talk
evaluates to one if and only if the
inputs are equal
we can use properties of the equality
functions communication Matrix to reason
about its communication complexity
we know that functions with efficient
deterministic protocols have
communication matrices with low rank
the equality function's communication
Matrix has high rank
therefore we can conclude that there is
no efficient deterministic protocol for
equality
however there is an efficient randomized
protocol for equality that uses hashing
what other functions have efficient
randomized protocols
one such function is the greater than
function interpreting our inputs as
numbers is X greater than y
the fact that equality has an efficient
randomized protocol makes it easy to
show that the greater than function does
as well
We Run The equality protocol multiple
times to binary search for the first
coordinate I where X and Y differ
then Alice and Bob exchange x i and y i
if x i is greater than y i
then X is greater than y
we used a reduction here so this
randomized protocol can be described
equally well as a deterministic protocol
with access to an equality Oracle
certainly every function with an
efficient equality Oracle protocol also
has an efficient randomized protocol
this raises the question of the converse
does every function with an efficient
randomized protocol also have an
efficient equality Oracle protocol
chatapatia Lovett and venials answer
this in the negative
the goal of our paper is to continue
investigating the relationship between
equality oracles and Randomness
specifically in this work we studied
what happens when you add
non-determinism to these models
furthermore you'll note that we really
needed to use many Oracle calls to
equality in the greater than protocol
what happens when we only allow one
we give answers to these questions in
terms of properties of the communication
Matrix there are four models here that
we give characterizations of
the first is the non-deterministic model
with multiple Oracle calls to the
equality function denoted NP to the EQ
in the second we only allow a single
Oracle call and this is denoted
exists.eq
it turns out that there are particularly
clean characterizations of two more
models that are perhaps a bit more
esoteric
these models have unambiguous
non-determinism which means that for
every input on which the function
evaluates to one there is exactly one
witness that the prover can send the
models are denoted up to the EQ and U
dot EQ respectively the main building
blocks of our characterizations are
blocking matrices
a matrix is a blocky Matrix if it is an
identity Matrix or some rearrangement of
the identity Matrix maybe we duplicate
or delete some rows or columns maybe we
permute some rows or columns
the important thing is that blocky
matrices are exactly the set of matrices
that can be recognized by a single
equality Oracle call
we Define the blocky covering number of
a zero one valued Matrix to be the
minimum size of a set of Blocky matrices
whose entry-wise or equals that Matrix
the blocky partition number is the
minimum size of a set of Blocky matrices
whose entry-wise sum equals that Matrix
to better illustrate these here's an
example
I claim that the blocky covering number
of this Matrix isn't most three
to prove that this is the case I will
demonstrate that this Matrix is the
entry-wise or of three blocking matrices
here is a drawing that represents the
first blocky Matrix
here is the second
and here's the third here are all three
together
note that all of the ones of the Matrix
are covered and no zeros of the Matrix
are covered and so this is valid to
demonstrate the blocky covering number
is at most three
we call this set of three matrices a
blocky cover
to show that the blocky covering number
is exactly three I would need to prove
that I couldn't cover all of the ones
and none of the zeros with fewer blocky
matrices notice that there's a lot of
overlap in the matrices in this blocky
cover this means it wouldn't be a valid
blocky partition for that measure the
support of the matrices should be
disjoint
another characterization we develop in
this work relates to the gamma 2
factorization Norm
the gamma 2 factorization Norm asks us
to factor our Matrix as the product of
two matrices whose rows have low L2 Norm
here the shorthand R of X means the
maximum L2 Norm of any row of x
this is a well-studied norm with
wide-ranging applications
we introduce the binary variant of the
gamma-2 norm in this paper binary gamma
2 is defined in the same way as the
standard gamma 2 except now the factor
matrices must only have entries equal to
zero or one
now I can tell you how these
characterizations of the communication
Matrix relate to our models
the complexity of a function in the
unambiguous non-deterministic
communication with a quality oracle's
model is bounded up to poly logarithmic
factors by the logarithm of the blocky
partition number as well as the
logarithm of the binary gamma-2 Norm of
that function's communication Matrix
in the normal non-deterministic with a
quality Oracle model a similar bound can
be gotten from blocky cover number and a
variant of binary gamma 2 that I won't
Define in this talk note something
interesting here because these bounds
are tight up to poly logarithmic factors
we've shown that for these
non-deterministic models having one
equality Oracle call is about as good as
having mini equality Oracle calls
this is interesting because the same is
not true in the deterministic case
there allowing for more equality Oracle
calls will give you a stronger model of
communication as a consequence of our
characterizations we get easy proofs of
some prior results I'll tell you a
couple of examples
the first example is a result of
chatapotie mande and Sharif who
disproved a conjecture called The Log
approximate rank conjecture by giving a
function called sync xor with high
randomized complexity but low
approximate rank
our characterization can be used to
reprove the fact that this function has
low approximate rank
sync xor is a composed function I will
first Define the single input function
sync consider the complete graph
each edge of the complete graph is
associated with one of the bits of the
input
this edge here is associated with input
bit z i
the value of zi will assign a direction
to the edge
we do this for the entire graph and ask
whether or not this directed graph has a
sink
this one does
in order to make this a two-party
communication function we compose sync
with xor
this is very simple it just means that
every bit of Z is the exclusive or of
bits from X and Y
there is a simple protocol for sync xor
that uses unambiguous non-determinism
and a single equality Oracle call
first the prover announces the vertex V
that is a sink if there is one
note that there can only be one sync in
the complete graph with directions so
this is an unambiguous Witness
now the parties have to verify that this
witness is correct
to do so Alice can compute the value W
that Bob's bits need to take in order
for the vertex V to be a sink
here the notation y v means the input y
restricted to the bits that involve
edges incident to V
Alice computes W locally
now they use a single equality call to
verify that w and y v are actually equal
if they are they know that the witness
was correct
we gave an efficient U dot EQ protocol
for the function our characterization of
U dot EQ shows that this means that the
communication Matrix of Sync xor has low
binary gamma 2 which of course means it
has low gamma 2.
a result of Lee and shriveman that gamma
2 is lower bounded by approximate rank
completes the proof
note that since sync xor does not have
an efficient randomized protocol it also
does not have an efficient deterministic
protocol with a quality oracles
that latter model is denoted P to the EQ
here
this separates P to the EQ from u p to
the EQ which is interesting because of
what happens when you leave out the
equality Oracle
if a function has an efficient protocol
with unambiguous non-determinism it also
has an efficient deterministic protocol
another application from our
characterizations is that we can improve
the aforementioned separation between a
quality Oracle calls and Randomness ma
is the class corresponding to Merlin
Arthur communication which is a
non-deterministic step followed by a
randomized step
our techniques can be combined with the
proof of chatapatia loves to separate NP
to the EQ from ma I'd like to sketch the
proof here for you the main tool here
was introduced by Chaturbate and vinyos
a lower bound method that uses the ratio
between the number of ones in a
function's communication Matrix denoted
Alpha and the square root of the size of
the largest rectangle composed entirely
of ones denoted beta
they proved that if a function has an
efficient P to the EQ protocol this
ratio must be low
we extend their proof to show that this
also holds for functions with efficient
NP to the EQ protocols
this can be shown using our connection
to blocky covering number
recall that NP to the EQ complexity is
tightly characterized by blocky covering
number the number of Blocky matrices
needed to cover the ones of the
communication Matrix
each of these blocky matrices in the
cover is composed of rectangles
notice that by the structure of blocking
matrices only one rectangle from each of
the blocky matrices can be contained in
any row or column
for example this row has three
rectangles one each from the three
blocky matrices
this row here only has two rectangles
which is fine
this holds for every row and every
column of the Matrix each has at most
three rectangles
using this observation and the AMG em
inequality we obtain a series of
inequalities that I'll show briefly on
the screen you can pause here or check
out the paper if you're interested to
know the details
the conclusion of these inequalities is
that we can bound the sum of the square
roots of the areas of all of the
rectangles in our cover by an expression
that involves the number of blocking
matrices in that cover
remember that the value beta from the
ratio is the maximum area of any
rectangle of ones in our Matrix
so of course the rectangles on our cover
have area at most beta
furthermore the value Alpha from the
ratio is the number of ones overall
which of course cannot be more than the
sum of the total areas of these
rectangles as these rectangles cover all
the ones in The Matrix
combining these constraints and doing a
bit of optimization we get the desired
bound
for the remainder of the talk I'd like
to speak about the open problems that we
list on our paper
one of these I would consider a hard
problem and another two were solved
between the writing of this paper and
this conference
the remaining three problems are in my
opinion excellent directions for future
research
I will use the rest of my time talking
about the last two problems here because
I think they most elegantly demonstrate
how the tools we introduced in this
paper might be used
recall from before that our techniques
were able to separate deterministic
communication with equality from
unambiguously non-deterministic
communication with equality
which is perhaps surprising because the
models have similar strength without the
equality oracles
there is another known collapse of
limited non-determinism to determinism
and communication
showed that if a function has both an
efficient non-deterministic protocol and
an efficient co-non-deterministic
protocol then it also has an efficient
deterministic protocol
this raises an obvious question what
happens with equality oracles
note that this is also open if we make
the non-determinism unambiguous
one way our techniques might help solve
these is the connection to the lower
bound technique mentioned previously
where the blocky cover number and
therefore the NP to the EQ complexity of
a function is lower bounded by the ratio
between the number of ones and the
square root of the largest one rectangle
we can use this fact to show that if a
function has a low NP to the EQ
complexity and it has a lot of ones the
function has a large all one's rectangle
similarly if a function has low Co NP to
the EQ complexity and it has a lot of
zeros it has a large all zeros rectangle
combining these if the function has low
NP to the EQ and low Co NP to the EQ
complexity it definitely has a large
rectangle that is either all zeros or
all ones
this is a strong restriction on the
structure of the function's
communication Matrix that may be
exploitable
thank you for listening to my talk bye